[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
you just try to blame me for some reason
no i mean i was just saying like
i was thinking about it more
this past week because it's been i know
you can't hide from it anymore the
government's final witness testifies
against accused sarah lawrence sex cult
leader lawrence ray plus was it patient
care or murder to my knowledge fentanyl
has never been used
in lethal injection the defense calls
its one and only witness in the trial of
ex-icu doctor william husser and
hello hello and good morning it's potito
family vs laundry family why brian
laundry's parents say a civil lawsuit
should be dismissed but first the
olympian attempted murder trial did you
want
that
bastard
finish
yes cross examination heats up as
shooting victim lauren kanarak takes a
stand for a second day law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
brian buckmart along with terry austin
we begin with news out of new jersey
where for the second day in a row
shooting victim lauren canarack takes a
stand as a prosecution star witness all
this has cantarak's former dressage
trainer and one-time olympian michael
barisson stands trial for her attempted
murder
barristone is also charged with the
attempted murder of canorax then
boyfriend robert goodwin the charges
date back to 2019 when barristone shot
lauren canorack in the chest twice and
also fired shots at goodwin following a
string of back and forth arguments about
canorax living arrangement at the time
the shoot of the shooting kanarak and
goodwin were living on barriston's
property as barrisone trained canorak in
dressage horseback riding in the days
leading up to the shooting a string of
911 calls were made by both parties
barristone saying he tried to evict
kanarak and kanarak saying she was being
harassed
defense attorneys say barazone feared
for his life at the time of the shooting
and suffered from mental health issues
even sleeping in a stable leading up to
the shooting on cross-examination
canerack told jurors how she reacted in
the moments following the shooting
somewhere in between
after i
told 9-1-1
i'd been shot
rob was
you know you could hear him struggling
with michael
at that time
i
grabbed my phone
i was turning blood
i crawled somewhere whether it was an
inch away or
half a foot away
to get my phone thinking the only way
that i could help the situation
is
by helping to make sure no one else gets
shot or killed that day
which is
why
i had my phone and was hitting my ball
on the head with it
you're with it
how long
were you beating michael barrasson with
your phone
maybe a matter of seconds
you're sure of that
pretty sure yes i didn't have
yeah yes i'm definitely sure that
do you recall previously saying
that you used your seven minutes to help
rob
by keeping the six foot four mv subdued
by breaking my phone in his cheek and in
his ear
do you recall saying that you were
beating him for seven
minutes
let's not wait a second mr blencus
that's not what it said
okay let's not don't characterize things
ask a question if you're reading from
something read the specific words do not
characterize it okay
did you say these exact words
i used my seven minutes
to help rob
keep the six foot four
m b
subdued
by breaking my iphone on his cheek and
in his ear
probably said that
seven minutes you claim to be beating
michael paris
joining us today is legal analyst dina
dahl and terry austin as we break down
the testimony of michael barrasson's
trial dean of the prosecution was smart
to warn jurors that they may not like
counteract behavior especially based on
her social media post bash embarrassment
but could a lack of sympathy for the
victims lead to an acquittal
you know in this case i think it may be
more
persuasive than in other cases because
the victim is also a witness and kind of
a key witness because there's not a lot
of you know evidence around exactly what
happened other than what each of them
have said the defendant and the victim
so her credibility becomes very
important and those social media posts
how she comes across on the stand
ultimately will help the jurors believe
who was the harasser here who did kind
of initiate this they both say it was
the other person and and this is how the
juror is going to sort that out to see
who they believe for themselves yeah
credibility and likability are probably
like cousins very different but uh still
somewhat related uh terry berason's
girlfriend mary haskins explained that
tara she and barisone felt do you think
that's enough for self-defense and do
you think she's testifying because he
can't or won't
well i do think she's testifying because
he probably will not testify certainly
because he has some mental illness and
he is very weak and he seems very shaken
but i thought mary was a great witness
for the defense even though the
prosecution called her for their case
she basically confirmed everything that
the defense was claiming in their
opening statement she frankly confirmed
that lauren was hassling and bullying on
facebook she basically said he was
trying to
she was trying to ruin his reputation
and and that that really made him very
fearful she said she saw him in a fetal
position so she confirmed all of the
things that the defense is trying to
claim including that mental illness yeah
prosecutors are probably trying to take
the sting out of her testimony by
calling her rather than having the
defense call her instead uh we'll keep
eyes on this case as it continues thank
you both on update now on our story we
first brought you on long crime daily
the body of missing 18 year old naomi
irion is recovered in nevada irian went
missing from a walmart parking lot more
than two weeks ago while waiting for a
shuttle to work officials say a tip came
in on tuesday that led investigators to
the 18 year old's body it was found
nearly two hours away from where she was
last seen alive last week 41 year old
troy driver was arrested and charged in
connection to irion's kidnapping and
disappearance a judge ruled on wednesday
driver's bail is set for 750 thousand
dollars if bail is posted he cannot be
released until a gps monitor is
installed
still ahead on law and crime daily both
sides rest in the case of ex-icu doctor
william husso but first the petito
family versus the laundry family how
brian laundry's parents hope to get a
civil lawsuit dismissed
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily an
update in the saga of the gabby petito
and brian launcher case as laundry's
parents are now looking to get a lawsuit
against them filed by patino's parents
dismissed the potato case captured the
nation's attention when the 22 year old
went missing while she and laundry her
boyfriend traveled on a cross-country
trip together months later he showed up
in a florida without her then roughly
two weeks later he too disappeared that
led to a nationwide search and the
findings of petito's remains in wyoming
it was ruled she died by strangulation a
month later laundry's remains were found
in a florida reserve his death was ruled
a suicide the potatoes lawsuit argues
laundry's parents knew their son had
killed petito and were working to help
him flee the country the laundry family
attorney is calling the lawsuit baseless
and frivolous and says his parents quote
exercise their constitutional rights to
refrain from speaking and relied on
counsel to speak for them
back to break down the latest potido
laundry saga is legal analyst dino doll
and terry austin terry do you think
there is a chance that gabby petito's
parents may actually prevail in the
civil suit against brian laundry's
parents
you know what brian unfortunately i
don't think they will prevail i think
this is one of the saddest cases that
we've ever seen when you read that
complaint and i've read it several times
it tells the story and it's a very
unfortunate story clearly brian's
parents were not saying anything they
hired a lawyer immediately and gabby's
parents are claiming that the
parents of brian knew more than they
were saying but they don't have any
obligation to say what they knew they
talked through their attorney and the
complaint actually doesn't even spell
out causes of action like intentional
emotional distress and i think that
basically it is just a story that
they're telling and it's a true story
but it's a sad story but i don't think
they're going to prevail yeah now dina
maybe there's a crazy thought here but i
get the laundries wanting the lawsuit
dismiss but if it's baseless and they
can prove that doesn't that mean they
should also be suing the potatoes for
defamation
so it's interesting in order for them to
make a defamation claim the potatoes
would have to have made a statement
outside of the complaint itself because
the com anything that they say in the
complaint is covered under litigation
privilege we want people to kind of make
their case in front of the court so
you're not subject to defamation based
on what you say in the complaint only
outside of it the other thing too is
that the burden of proof is very
different if the suit prevails it's up
to the petito family to prove what they
knew if they decide to sue for
defamation the burden would shift and
they would have to prove that they
didn't know which is harder to do and it
would make more sense for them just to
continue to dismiss it or win in this
case interesting sounds like uh like
sound legal advice and that's probably
why they're doing it here thank you both
coming up on law and crime daily federal
prosecutors call on yet another alleged
victim of the accused sara lawrence sex
cult leader lawrence ray to testify plus
both sides rest in ohio as a former
doctor faces charges of patient murder
hear from the defense his only witness
in the trial of william hussell next
[Music]
welcome back after weeks of testimony
from prosecution witnesses the defense
begins and quickly ends its case in the
trial of ex-icu doctor william hussell
whosoever's accused of murdering
multiple patients by giving them a
lethal dose of the drug fentanyl while
prosecutors say whoso murdered all 14
victims defense attorneys say husso was
providing end-of-life comfort for those
in need in all the prosecution called 53
witnesses over nearly six weeks the
defense headed by famed attorney jose
baez began its case on wednesday calling
its first and only witness a critical
care specialist to the stand
first of all i guess you know the
question is is dying painful at all
and i think the answer is that yes dying
is presumably very painful to watch it
having watched it many times uh it it
looks it that it can be quite painful
for people why
because um you know they
based upon simple things like simply
what they say you know people may say
i'm in pain if they can or they may you
know make sounds you know of moaning or
in the way that their body moves and and
uh just bringing to bear one's own
empathy you know the empathy of another
person suffering that we can recognize
it you know we're tooled for it we can
see it we can see it
even very slightly you know it's it's
it's our common humanity
and so i see it all the time and you
know i i i'm i register it i'm affected
by it
uh as my job as a physician i don't want
to leave it sitting you know i want to
seek to relieve the pain and suffering
of the patients that i care for
the defense residents case thursday
morning closing arguments are expected
to be presented on monday
legal analyst dina dahl and co-host
terry austin are back as we discuss who
sells defense terry one and only one
witness did the defense need this
witness and if so how did he help
i absolutely think this was a very smart
move on the part of the defense to call
one witness a critical care specialist
who can explain to the jury why it is
important to give this comfort care that
patients go through pain when they
actually are going through the death
process and if he had called multiple
witnesses i think that would have been a
problem we know already that 53
witnesses over six weeks is a very long
time you just need this one and only
witness particularly since i think the
defense did a great job on
cross-examination of the prosecution's
witnesses so good move on the part of
the defense and i think i'll add that it
also makes a lot of sense because when
we think about so many of our first
responders and caregivers and now in
times and seeing so many people die i
think people can kind of connect with
that and say yeah that's that's harmful
to them as well uh dina so whoso doesn't
testify are you shocked and do you think
this was the right decision by the
ex-doctor
i mean i agree with terry i think this
is really smart there's a lot of risks
than putting the defense on the stand
they could bring in prior bad acts he
could have maybe performed poorly on
cross-examination it would have been an
ex
looking into what his particular
threshold of pain is like and maybe how
that differs from others and also the
expert is much better at speaking to the
really the two issues that's so
important which is causation you know
the jury is going to take put much more
weight into what an unbiased expert
thinks about that than than husel so i
think that they did a good job
he couldn't have added that much more
than the expert did and there were risks
involved absolutely well we'll see how
this all connects when closing arguments
are presented to the jury and of course
we'll be giving you a gallon of gavel
coverage here at the law and crime
network when we come back another victim
takes the stand in the federal trial for
accused sarah lawrence sex cult leader
lawrence wray our adam classo is at the
federal courthouse with the latest
developments
[Music]
welcome back the government is soon
expected to rest its case in the federal
trial of accused ceremonies sex cult
leader lawrence ray but before calling
another alleged victim julissa rosario
the sibling of two other witnesses who
have already testified for the
prosecution
ray faces several federal charges
including tax evasion racketeering sex
trafficking and money laundering among
others he's accused of running a sex
cult over the last decade which he
allegedly started out of his daughter's
on-campus housing at sarah lawrence
college in 2010. jurors have heard from
several of rey's alleged victims
including claudia jury who told the jury
about becoming a prostitute at rey's
suggestion to which the she testified
was a way for her to pay him back for
the crimes he says she committed against
him jurors also heard from alleged
victim santos rosario who was a student
at sarah lawrence and a boyfriend of
talia ray the defendant's daughter his
two sisters were students at columbia
university they were brought into the
alleged sex cult by their brother a
video of one of the sisters
was shown to the jury wednesday showing
rey bombarding her with questions about
her mental state
so why are you throwing this mood around
do you want to hurt yourself
do you
yeah
i asked you a direct question ally
please answer the question
yeah
do you ever feel like you just want
something to be wrong with you
you can answer it yes or no
oh yeah
and when do you think about that
like in relation to what or home
they wanted something to be wrong with
me
yeah we keep talking um because she was
like she like fucked me up so
she what
she fucked me up like when i was younger
and you've been thinking about that
and i haven't been like i was never a
normal normal person
and how long you've been thinking about
that um we thinking about that more
since past week
why
because i
you're
you're
pointing things out about what i do and
like
how i've been
let's cop out
that was cheap shot y'all
law and crime's adam klasfeld has spent
the duration of this trial inside the
courtroom he has details on the
defense's plans once they begin making
their case before the jury
i was reviewing some defense filings
you know they're previewing what they're
going to say
and because of all of these videos
because of all these evidence it doesn't
seem like they're going to meaningfully
question the allegations against him the
defense that they're floating at this
time is an advice of council defense
larry ray plans to argue if he's
permitted to do it that his lawyer said
that this would be permissible to
collect money as compensation as
restitution for
and these string of offenses which
prosecutors say were was totally
imagined that he wasn't poisoned they
say by a claudia jury and was not
entitled to make millions off of her
alleged sex trafficking
i mean i want to find out who that
lawyer is their bar license is probably
in trouble uh dina let's focus on the
defense for a minute because it's
shaping up in a way
let's say interesting way the defense is
suggesting this was all aggressive
encounter therapy
what's that and does it make sense here
so the defense is saying that this
therapy that was popular in the 1960s
and 70s where the therapists would put
their patients into uncomfortable
situations in order to get past their
trauma but people don't get prosecuted
for putting people into uncomfortable
situations you know so even if there is
that theory most likely it's been
debunked since then but still you know a
therapist who did the things he did
could still be charged with a crime
that's not a defense so it seems um i
think fairly flimsy it might
uh resonate though with uh one or two
jurors and i think that's what the
defense is hoping yeah now terry
therapist gets therapists get paid so is
the defense suggestion that he is
providing therapy thus is entitled to
compensation holding water to you
no it's not holding any water as far as
i'm concerned this wasn't therapy i
think like dina said there's therapy
where you are helping people but you are
helping them remember these difficult
times and you're bringing them through
those times so that they can heal that's
not what he was doing here he was
hurting these individuals both
physically emotionally mentally there
was no therapy here and to say that he
is entitled to compensation i think is a
bit ironic to say the least he should
have been charged criminally he has been
charged criminally and don't forget ryan
he has been in jail before for
committing other crimes he's been
charged in the past so this is something
that he has done as a matter of habit
and so i definitely think that they have
a lot of evidence against him pretty
interesting to see how this plays out of
course we still have to wait on the
defense's case well thank you both and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you